alex jones is now begging for
money from his audience for the lawsuit
that he lost
on the wednesday bonus show i told you
that
in a case uh where the plaintiffs
are sandy hook parents of victims from
the sandy hook shooting in 2012
the plaintiffs are suing alex jones for
defamation
the court has found against jones but
not on the merits yet
on the basis that jones is obstructing
discovery that's the finding so far so
he's trying to prevent this from even
getting to the next level where he may
actually be found liable for damages for
defamation itself
alex jones is now saying he needs money
he needs two million dollars
in order to pay for all of this take a
look at what he had to say
trials even though i've already been
found guilty by default now they're
gonna try to tell the jury how guilty i
am
now even that's deceptive i've been
found guilty by default
you obstructed discovery you're supposed
to allow discovery and you didn't it's
not guilty by default it's you're not
allowing discovery it's going to take a
lot of money to fight this and a lot of
money
for the appeals and so i can't spend the
money we have paying our crew and
running our independent media outlet
that drives millions of people right
without your support infowars is doing
its most important work ever right now
so i would argue that that's not true
this is a no-brainer please go to save
infowars.com make a ten donation a
thousand dollar donation wealthy people
out there
your free speech is being destroyed
infowars is just the first you know uh
most wealthy people
most people but certainly most wealthy
people know
their free speech is not being destroyed
their free speech is fine i'm going to
fall and if wealthy folks don't start
spending their money promoting liberty
promoting freedom we're going to lose
this country and we're going to lose the
world to tyranny so please go to
saveinfowars.com it's give sin go
they're great folks they're patriots
we're banned everywhere else even be
able to raise money and this will help
keep us the fight for the next few years
so i've never issued an alert this
serious i need your help right now
that's also not true there's always some
alert stand up for yourself stand up for
your right stand up for free speech
stand up for america and don't let these
bullies intimidate anybody please donate
right now and save him okay
now that is what desperation looks like
but i hate to tell you guys
he's raising a bunch of money this uh
campaign started a day and a half ago
the goal is two million dollars he's
already raised just a few dollars short
of a hundred thousand dollars by the
time that this uh clip gets published
and today's podcast gets published
it may be a lot more money so this is
what desperation looks and sounds like
um i guess the risk is we may lose
infowars altogether if we don't donate
to alex jones which doesn't seem like it
would really be that bad of a thing
quite frankly it seems like actually
that that might be uh something that has
positive influence so alex jones as i
told you
not yet actually found liable uh on the
merits of the defamation case but they
are declining to actually do what
they're supposed to do when it comes to
discovery to even allow
this to go forward despite a judge's
request slash demands depending on what
you want to call them
and now alex jones is turning it into
the grift of grifts
he made money by making by lying about
sandy hook he then got sued and now he's
trying to make money by painting himself
as the victim as a result of not
participating in what the court said he
has to do
discovery for this case uh i don't think
anybody in my audience is going to
donate but people are donating he's
already up to almost a hundred thousand
dollars and probably more by the time we
publish this clip it's an amazing time
that we live in
um i want to remind everybody again we
will be off next week thursday and
friday for the thanksgiving holiday just
so people don't email me say david
where's the show where's the show we're
going to be off thursday and friday we
will be here monday tuesday wednesday
we're going to take a quick break i want
to hear from some of you i have
questions to answer i have emails to
address and show you you can also of
course find me on twitter at dpakman
look forward to hearing from you
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlas vpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information if i turn on atlas vpn
before logging into netflix hulu or
amazon i can access streaming content
from other countries i can even watch
stuff from argentina like soccer i use
atlas vpn on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
atlas vpn is having a huge black friday
sale giving you 86
off comes out to like a dollar 39 a
month for a subscription plus you'll get
three months free just go to atlas v dot
pn slash pacman the link is down below